your book is so beautiful and i always
want to ask when i see something so
brilliant like to the last bite sure
what a rich concept talk to me about
what's behind it and how this title was
waiting for only you totally i mean i
think we're all kind of collectively
trying to be more conscious trying to be
more eco-friendly and more sustainable
and i think a lot of us don't really
know what that means and i thought
growing up in the catskills and kind of
in this kind of culture of reusing
everything and then working in food
media i had this like unique perspective
to put this cookbook together well this
book is one of the sexiest most
beautiful guides i've ever seen really
i'm so excited
and
i'm excited
for what we are going to make today now
you're the driver i am your passenger
i'm getting in your car
take it away okay so today we're making
eggplant parm i love it because it's
vegetarian it feeds a crowd i mean who
doesn't love eggplant harm i mean it's
got all the good stuff tons of cheese
we're in all right so we've got the
onions we've got the onions going for 30
minutes they're getting caramelized and
browned and they just smell amazing
we're gonna add the garlic
you know and we're just gonna stir that
for about 30 seconds until aromatic i'm
gonna also say i love adding garlic
later so that it doesn't burn exactly is
that why this is happening exactly why
it's happening okay so now garlic we can
smell it add the tomato paste i have to
say
if there's one condiment you keep around
in your pantry or fridge tomato paste
tomato paste i mean you can do so much
with that it's such a building block of
flavor it's like got that real umami and
then you're just going to give that a
good stir yeah you can add the spices
we've got red pepper flakes salt and
pepper
and we just don't want to kind of cook
that until the tomato paste turns like
brick red okay this looks amazing so
next we're going to add the tomatoes
okay and you know be careful that they
don't spill
but lauren our culinary director gave me
a hot tip which is if you hold on
pour the tomato sauce onto the wooden
spoon
it stops the splatter
so
once again thank you st lauren amazing
so give that a good stir and we're just
going to let that simmer for 30 minutes
goodbye sauce okay so we've got the
eggplant
and i like to salt my eggplant and let
it kind of sit for about an hour this
like helps draw out the moisture so you
don't have like soggy eggplant you know
no one wants that smart okay so now it's
true it's too soggy otherwise we're
gonna take some salt pepper to season
the flour you can be really generous
with this no this is just adding flavor
i love this so i'm just dredging it
really lightly in flour first
and then into the egg
flour then egg flour then egg thank you
so much and is this a panko and then
panko and i like to use panko rather
than breadcrumbs you know they're
lighter crunchy they add like a
crunchier exterior a few people have
asked me if you could bake this and you
coat totally and but i think frying it
just like
let's get honest here let's be honest
drying tastes better you could fry a
shoe and i'd be into it
i would eat it too
after you
actually tried that and paul and
eggplant i love life i just wanna
i wanna
i wanna get into it with all of it it's
all the good things a lot i know
you're perfect okay so once you've fried
the eggplant it's going to be golden
brown just like this
and we're just going to leave that there
yeah
we're going to move on and if you want
to help me actually build this yes
please so first we're going to layer the
eggplant layer the eggplant one layer
with some sauce on top yes is what i'm
seeing and then some parm so you're
going to use these and just layer them
up i'm not doing that we're doing a
whole new layer okay a whole new layer
and then okay i'll add the sauce and you
you know
how much sauce you like
i mean
whatever you're doing and i see the
onions that's what i love it hasn't lost
that it hasn't become so translucent and
congealed so now you're going to add
parmesan and you can be pretty generous
with that i've already spilled it out
everywhere this is i'm messy
and then we're just going to add the
mats on top
and i like to just add them like full on
like it's just going to be a full-on
cheese situation here
we're going to pop this in the oven at
400 degrees for
yeah thank you 55 minutes or until it
gets like nice and golden in public what
temp 400 degrees 55 minutes 455. got it
and then it comes out looking
like that oh my god
movie magic
i mean
[Applause]
[Laughter]
little personal ones too
um
at least i own it
oh okay i know this is my own recipe but
i'm so excited
i know i feel bad eating in front of
people i do
i mean i'm excited and i'm gonna do it
but
i know
i know oh my god it's so good can i say
that it's so good it's so good and it's
got
that breadiness that you want
it's but not too much no no very light
the eggplant is perfect
it's not soggy it's got a great texture
i feel the seeds but i like when i have
like a nice tear to the flesh
you heard me i want to tear the flesh
same same
you need to like finish these in private
and maybe like that one too it's true i
eat like an alley cat i'm like look away
[Music]
i hit
and i turn my back i'm not good at like
public eating and dinner tables unless
it's with my friends but i'm like
i don't this is not the real me the real
me motor boats food and doesn't want
anyone looking
[Music]
you